foreign
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight sensit Russians feed the country
in droves as Putin drafts his 300 000
reservists they're worried for how
worried should we be about his nuclear
threat
trust and Biden Clash over Northern
Ireland because his very existence now
be in questioned as Catholics
outnumbered Protestants for the first
time we'll debate that
and Britain's strictest headmistress is
here live to give us a lesson in
teaching and in free speech
here's Morgan uncensored well good
evening from London welcome to Piers
Morgan uncensored these are turbulent
times for Britain the death of our great
Queen raise some big questions here
about what it means to be British and
what the future holds for the United
Kingdom itself could the age of King
Charles III see an independence Scotland
or perhaps even before that a unified
Island personally I hope not I like the
United Kingdom as it is but one thing's
for sure if either of these countries do
redefine themselves or they both do they
will do it by choice in free and fair
elections with results that we will have
to respect because we respect democracy
here I think Scottish independence would
be a disaster mostly for Scotland but if
they do vote to leave I'll send them on
their way and I'll wish them luck same
would apply to Ireland it would be their
choice and that's the beauty of
democracy Now compare that to the fake
Frankenstein democracy of Russia a
country with a dictator starts balance
to give his murderous regime Hashem
credibility where government critics end
up with novichok in their underpants
they haven't already mysteriously fallen
out of Windows Russia is now using this
pathetic pretensive democracy to justify
further genocide in Ukraine this weekend
is holding fake votes in Ukraine's
occupied East supposedly on whether the
people there want to become formally
part of Russia again they don't
we won't need to wait until results
tonight the outcome of this one Peter
Moore declared victory
a delusional leader must be further lies
about protecting the Russian people and
he'll again threaten the West with
nuclear Armageddon the ukrainians made
their choice when they became a
sovereign Democratic country
they chose to be independent they chose
president zielinski in a landslide and
he's leading a heroic fight to protect
that right to choose NATO should be
backing him and backing him hard until
this fight for Freedom democracy is one
well joining me now is nuclear weapons
expert Alex wallastine is also a nuclear
historian I'm also joined by commentator
and lawyer Paula Roan Adrian talked to
the international editor Isabel oakshot
and historian Neil Ferguson so a stellar
lineup to kick off tonight's show
um let me start if I can with you Alex
uh wallerstein because a lot of talk at
the moment about nuclear weapons and yet
very few of us know much about nuclear
weapons we know about Nagasaki and
Hiroshima and how devastating they were
but thank God we've not had any
repetitions since however many experts
believe we are now on the precipice of
potentially having to face up to some
kind of nuclear weapon being used by
Vladimir Putin perhaps of the Tactical
variety I don't know what that means in
reality can you tell us what is a
tactical nuclear weapon how big is it
how powerful is it How likely is it that
Vladimir Putin may use one
thanks a bunch Bears I'm happy to be
here a tactical nuclear weapon tells you
less about how big the weapon is and
more about what it would be intended to
be used against so a tactical nuclear
weapon is something like a battlefield
nuclear weapon as opposed to a strategic
nuclear weapon which might be aimed at a
city or a silo or so on they tend to be
smaller in terms of their explosive
output uh they but but smaller here is
all very relative so the weapon dropped
on Hiroshima in 1945 that could be a
tactical nuclear weapon uh in the today
or in the Cold War if you used it
against tanks and they can range in how
explosive they are down to levels that
are almost like the biggest conventional
explosives we have there's still nuclear
weapons but they're generally much
smaller than the ones that would be
aimed at sort of a city but they're
still pretty powerful the whole point of
nuclear weapons in a modern society is
supposedly for deterrent the theory
being that big superpowers build up a
nuclear Arsenal and it deters anybody
from using nuclear weapons because
everyone gets vaporized How likely is it
do you think that somebody like Putin
cornered possibly losing now in this in
this war that he has to win that he may
resort to this and what would be the
repercussions I mean President Biden has
said he would respond but doesn't want
to say how he would respond what what in
reality would happen do you think
uh we don't know and I don't think
President Biden knows and I don't think
Putin knows and keeping that uncertainty
is partially what uh is believed to
maintain this state of deterrence in the
sense that it might be a little response
it might be a bigger response uh keeping
him uncertain about what the outcome
would be is a deliberate strategy so
that it's hard for him to calculate what
might be in his interests and that he
might hope uh whatever he might hope he
might get out of it uh he probably would
have to balance against what other
consequences would come so the answer is
nobody really knows and there probably
isn't a Doctrine written somewhere that
says if he does X we do y uh it's the
sort of thing that the president or
Putin would have to decide under the
circumstances and that you know makes
people a little uncomfortable to to put
it into the decision of a single human
being the other question I mean just on
the numbers Russia has the highest
number of nuclear foreheads just under
six thousand America has just under five
and a half thousand then China France
and the UK all have between 350 and 225.
uh obviously you know one or two of
these things can cause unbelievable
Mayhem and damage and destruction to uh
to people and to and to infrastructure
but how many of Russia's nuclear weapons
do we think would be usable I mean what
what actually is the reality of Putin's
nuclear Arsenal
so the new start treaty says that the
United States and Russia each agree to
have no more than one thousand five
hundred and fifty Warheads that are
strategically used again aimed at other
Warheads or aimed at military bases or
aimed at cities or industry and so on it
says nothing about tactical nuclear
weapons so they might have many of those
there's some estimates on how many they
have but uh so that sort of puts some
limits on those big numbers in terms of
how many would actually work in terms of
how many would reach their target how
many could come into play we don't
really know uh you could imagine a
situation in which somebody like Putin
wanted to use one small nuclear weapon
with the hope of avoiding larger
escalation or larger War you could also
Imagine a situation in which they
decided to launch everything in a
full-scale attack
um in that actually yeah
just to interrupt you I actually can't
imagine that because the idea of a
country like Russia unleashing hundreds
of nuclear weapons which would lead to
the almost inevitable destruction of the
entire planet very quickly is actually
unimaginable to most of us
I think uh to war planners it's much
more imaginable uh I steep myself in the
historical literature on this and
they've imagined it they've worked out
how it would work they've worked out
what it would be how many they think
would die but of course they fought as
many nuclear Wars as you and I have so
who knows how much of that would play
out in practice right uh Alice honestly
I mean fascinating slightly terrifying I
have to say but I appreciate you joining
me thank you very much let me go to Neil
Ferguson no problem thank you Neil
you're a historian like Alex
in your estimation where are we here are
we closer to nuclear conflict than the
world has ever been perhaps even closer
than we were in the Cuban Missile Crisis
no uh and this is uh at this point it's
a much less dangerous situation than the
Cuban Missile Crisis in 1962 remember uh
in uh 1962 it was the United States and
the Soviet Union uh that were on the
brink of conflict after uh Khrushchev a
stationed missiles on uh Cuba just off
the U.S Coast and it was only uh by
sheer good luck that the war we might
have called World War III didn't break
out actually an order was given by a
Soviet submarine Commander to fire a
nuclear torpedo at some U.S surface
ships luckily he had a superior officer
on board who overruled him and so he
avoided World War III but it was an
extraordinarily dangerous moment clearly
the most dangerous moment of the Cold
War this is different and I'll try and
explain why first of all the Russian
Federation is not the Soviet Union it
turns out that it's conventional Army
can't even defeat Ukraine never mind
NATO and the only reason that Putin is
talking about tactical nuclear weapons
is because he knows he's losing this
conventional War secondly if you look
carefully at what he's saying actually
it's he he who is using the nukes as a
deterrent he's directing his rhetoric at
NATO at the U.S and its allies not at
Ukraine he's not saying that if Ukraine
keeps on winning he'll use a tactical
nuke against Ukrainian forces I think
what he's saying if one reads it
carefully is that he might use a nuclear
weapon if NATO were to escalate its
involvement in the war in fact in the
speech he just gave this week it's only
as if he was saying that NATO had
threatened Russia with nukes which I
must have missed maybe that was only
available on RT so this is not the Cuban
Missile Crisis these are the bluffing
blustering statements of a dictator who
is losing the small war that he thought
would be over in days and time is
running out for Vladimir Putin I don't
think to just make one final Point
Pierce even if he gave the order to
launch or drop a nuclear weapon that it
would be carried out right and that's a
really important point to remember he
doesn't get to deliver it personally
he'd need the order to be carried out
where do you think this goes then I
interviewed Jordan Peterson yesterday at
length and as part of that he was pretty
Doom Laden actually about what he
thought was going to happen he just
couldn't see a situation that didn't end
with Putin having some kind of victory
in Ukraine having to cede something to
Putin
um I mean there is a scenario I could
see here in relation to Putin's speech
where he's coming up with all these fake
referenda at the weekend in which he's
going to try and presumably declare you
know electoral victory in these fake
referendum just to find what he's doing
if Ukraine was to then attack those
areas which which have now supposedly
democratically declared themselves part
of Russia would he then use that as the
excuse for them attacking Russian land I
mean that seems to me a scenario that he
could react to
well that might be the rationale here
the problem is that even as he's trying
to organize this sham referenda he's
actually losing control of the territory
in question it's not like ukrainians
have stopped their offensive operations
they're ongoing and I think they will
press on taking advantage of the obvious
weakness and demoralization of the
Russian army I don't agree with Jordan
Peterson's gloomy take I was just in
cave about 10 days ago and met with
president zielinski at a time when
Ukraine was winning some remarkable
victories uh uh east of kharkiv and I
think that the ukrainians have a decent
chance of continuing to gain ground
because Russia's Army is a demoralized
colonial Force most of its troops drawn
from the back of Beyond of the Russian
Russian Federation I nearly said Empire
that's how Putin thinks of it and
they've suffered amazingly heavy
casualties peers if you look at the
death race that we can figure out maybe
something like a quarter of the initial
invading force is now dead so I think
there's a decent chance that Ukraine can
press its Advantage uh in the coming
weeks and months that's not going to
bring peace because Putin's not about to
admit defeat and accept that his
so-called military operations an epic
fail it seems to me that the the war
itself will continue but the level of
fighting will have to diminish both
sides simply can't keep this up uh
winter is of course approaching and my
estimate is that this will play out a
little bit like the Korean war did
that's to say the really kinetic phase
will give way to a somewhat protracted
stalemate there'll never be a peace
agreement because the two sides will
never agree but there'll be something
like an Armistice maybe sometime next
year and and that will be a moral
victory for Ukraine uh even if it's not
acknowledged officially in a peace
treaty right let's bring in you've been
very patient thank you very much but you
were both slightly recoiling at some of
the stuff we've been talking about here
because we you know having to even think
about a nuclear war is actually pretty
scary I mean I definitely prefer Nile
Ferguson's analysis to the nuclear
weapons expert yeah um but I'm not sure
I necessarily am that convinced by his
analysis was essentially what he's
saying you know he is very eminent and I
don't for a minute pretend that I know
better than him but on the other hand I
just don't think that President Putin is
going to be willing to contemplate
something that is perceived around the
world to be a failure and that is the
problem and this whole idea that um you
know he would have to be uh he would
need to use a NATO aggression as an
excuse well he invents NATO regression
as an excuse the whole time it's all a
complete fiction and if we revert as as
Professor Ferguson says to a kind of
long War of Attrition essentially that's
only going back to what was happening in
Ukraine back in well since 2013-14 ever
since then I don't think he's going to
be satisfied with that position well I
mean there's a big debate isn't there
about how committed we should be as a
country like all countries in Europe and
America and so on how much should we be
invested in Ukraine's Victory to me I
mean I like Neil Ferguson I've been to
Ukraine in the last two months we've
both been on the same train that show
talked to Neil in a moment about that
um we've been there we've met zielinski
he's a very impressive character he
could have disappeared from a city but
he stayed
um he's a real inspirational leader I
got the feeling they don't want to give
an inch no an inch to put him they don't
see he's an impressive strong Warrior
more than just a leader he is a warrior
leading his army into battle and he is
not going to return do we have a moral
duty to give him as much Firepower as we
can to win this battle which I think we
do because to me it's a battle not just
about Ukraine's democracy it's a battle
for European democracy for the world's
democracy and if we don't fight for that
what are we fighting for absolutely and
I I saw a survey recently where it did
say that um apparently the public would
now prefer the government to focus on
the cost of living crisis as opposed to
what's happening in Ukraine and we can
understand of course we can understand
that because the cost of living crisis
is an immediate concern but when we
understand why part of the reason that
we have a cost of living crisis is
because of what's happening in Ukraine
we can do nothing but support well I
think let's bring back Neil Ferguson on
this because to me this is the crucial
link really between the two things is
that a lot of the energy crisis issues
we have in the UK right now are driven
by this war in Ukraine so if for no
other reason the national
self-economic interest this is something
that we need to see one because
otherwise person will continue to
control energy through Europe in a very
nefarious manner
well I think pierce the days when Europe
relied on uh Russian natural gas and oil
are coming to an end and I don't think
they'll return anytime soon uh what's
happening right now is an irreversible
shift away uh from Russian gas and oil
uh and once uh Europe and the UK have
got through the coming winter it's not
like we'll be going rushing back to
Moscow to strike New Deals uh Putin's
blunder has isolated him from the West
in a way that will be extremely
difficult uh to change he's now going to
be selling his gas and oil at a discount
to the likes of of China uh I think the
the question is both a moral one I agree
with you peers uh we're fighting uh it's
supporting here a fight for democracy
and self-determination but there is also
a matter of uh of national self-interest
Russia has been a threat not only to
Ukraine but to the UK it's uh government
has carried out assassinations on
British soil and anything that weakens
the regime of Vladimir Putin is devoted
to be wished for and supported and there
is a real and I think uh extremely
exciting opportunity here uh to Humble
uh the Russian Federation uh and
Vladimir Putin and this I think will be
of great benefit not only uh to the UK
but also to the European Union which of
course allowed itself to become
disastrously dependent on Russian
natural gas so I think there are very
strong moral and practical reasons for
supporting uh this war effort and notice
because the UK is punching well above
its weight at this point its support uh
exceeds the support of many major
European countries uh in fact the UK is
really in many ways uh second lonely to
the US in its commitment not only its
financial and economic commitment but
its commitment in training Ukraine
Indian forces it's not just zielinski
who's the warrior here no and I'm
completely in favor of what Boris
Johnson started in this trust is going
to continue just before we let this go
and move on to other stuff you just went
I read your spectator diary you just
went to Kiev to see President zolenski
you went on the same night train that I
took this 12-hour train right through
Ukraine uh they put the blinds down and
tell you not to put any lights on which
is quite an interesting conversation
it's sort of a 12-hour Journey
um how did you find it how did you find
the people there I I detected a real
sense of stoic resilience and
determination driven by zielinski
himself he he basically motivated the
people to believe they can win this war
that's right peers and to see the nation
in arms as Ukraine is today is deeply
impressive zielinski deservedly gets a
lot of media coverage but Ukraine
wouldn't still be in this war wouldn't
in fact be winning it if it weren't for
the fact that the people have come
together uh both civilians and the
military in a way that very few of us
who know Ukraine expected or thought
possible that's the impressive thing
it's not just that zielinski is a
charismatic leader it's the fact that
the Ukrainian people have United and are
absolutely resolved to drive the
Russians out of their territory indeed
sentiment has become so positive in
recent weeks that they're now talking
about retaking Crimea retaking the land
that was lost back in 2014. yeah
absolutely and I hope they do
um take a short break but before we do
that we'll just
um say that tomorrow night we're going
to re-air my hour-long special interview
with president zolenski and his first
lady Elena zelensko which we ran in in
July I did it in July I think it's been
no more relevant now than ever perhaps
here's a little clip of as to why I
think that
do you believe you can win this war
yes no question yeah yeah
I don't only believe it I know it will
happen
we will win
it's a fascinating interview if you
didn't see it we're going to aerate in
full tomorrow night here on Facebook
when I'm censored at eight o'clock let's
take a short break we'll be back to talk
about the future of Britain the United
Kingdom for the first time more
Catholics than Protestants in Norman
what does that mean for us we'll debate
that next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Johnson's up to these days oh he's doing
this
thanks also of course to the
inspirational leadership of Vladimir
Putin
as the inspirational leadership of
Vladimir zielinski forgive me thanks
Boris good to hear from you again uh
well I've got my my pack with me again
let's talk about the future of this
country now because a lot of challenges
but one of the big challenges is the
potential certainly in the reign of King
Charles III for referendum both in
Scotland and potentially in Ireland now
with this Revelation there are now more
Catholics than there are Protestants
Sinn Fein is the dominant party things
are moving quite fast in Ireland and you
could see a situation where they have a
referendum on a United Island before
Scotland has another referendum but if
they did I don't actually think that
those separatists those that want to do
that would actually succeed I thought
that the more interesting statistics
actually if you read down those census
answers were the number of those who
answered about their identity over 30
percent felt British but that's way down
on what it was numbers but if you add
that to those that felt Northern Irish
you get over 50 people but the numbers
aren't falling on that British identity
but if you're if you're determined to
find a negative and a divisive spin on
it yes but actually overall you've still
got the majority of people very strongly
identifying either as British or
Northern Irish that doesn't say to me
that that is the ground that is needed
to lead to the breakup of the Paula what
do you feel about this I take a slightly
different view because for me I think
the shift is going to come from the
youth absolutely and I think when we
look at the youth and we look at their
response in the media they don't
identify as Catholic or Protestant it's
not simply about religious politics
anymore it's about who am I and what do
I want for the future and I suspect that
what they want for the future is a
unified country to be able to say to the
world this is who we are and this is who
we are together as one Neil Ferguson
you're a historian
um are we we've seen massive history on
furling in the last week with a new
monarch in this country the first In Our
Lifetime is it likely in King Charles
III's Reign that we might see a United
Ireland and an independent Scotland do
you think
it's not inconceivable peers but I
wouldn't say it was very likely I agree
with Isabelle's point if one looks
carefully there doesn't seem to be an
enormous yearning for Irish
reunification and it would be
reunifications only a century since the
partition that created Northern Ireland
as a separate entity from the Republic
I don't think that's uh really a key
issue uh that there are all kinds of
problems that exist largely as a result
uh of the way the brexit uh deal was
done by Boris Johnson a northern armed
in an anomalous situation inside the
single Market unlike the rest of the UK
I think that's one reason that this
issue is even being discussed and so
there's something to be resolved there
but that's the pressing issue not the
reunification of Ireland which is some
way off as for Scotland then I can speak
with more of course in that as a
Scotsman I think we'll look back and say
that Nicholas sturgeon best shot at
Independence was in 2014 and that it's
very very hard indeed for the SNP now to
argue that Scotland's problems are
somehow to do with being in the United
Kingdom because the SNP runs Scotland
pretty much every aspect of its domestic
policy and the fact that it's running it
very badly is gradually Dawning on
voters and that's the thing to watch
well there's a bigger existential threat
uh than any of this as far as I'm
concerned and it's this Barbara broccoli
who runs the 007 James Bond franchise
has apparently now come out and said
bond is evolving as men are evolving and
that the next actor to play the role
will continue the work of Daniel Craig
who cracked Bond open emotionally they
want more bigger roles for women and a
more sensitive 007 I'm not against
bigger roles for women although I do
think get your own spies but when it
comes to a sensitive James Bonds
we absolutely
no I think the next movie will have to
be called end of days there will be end
of days and by the way no one's gonna go
and see it if it's all working James
Bond to be a steely-eyed dealer of death
right a hard Drinker a hard smoker and a
Serial womanizer yeah who has no
emotional valve whatsoever he doesn't
care that's the whole point we and shall
I tell you why on a serious note why we
don't want that because we know how high
the male suicide rate is that's got
nothing to do not seriousness
what we want we're not blaming it on
James Bond what we're saying is great
James Bond is now turning into a real
human let me bring in Neil Ferguson on
this because you are a historian did I
mean this to me is almost the biggest
threat facing civilization as we know it
and overseas sensitive James Bond
it's a it's a terrifying Prospect to say
nothing of the metamorphosis of Doctor
Who uh look I'm a Sean Connery fan I I
even had the privilege of getting to
know Sean Connery and I I regard Daniel
Craig as slightly a feat by the
standards of Connery so it's been all
downhill since Sean hung up his toupee
I think he has listen Barbara broccoli
is watching and I had been pitching
myself as the next bomb because Pierce
Brosnan Pierce Morgan I mean he's not a
massive leap as I put it to and I do
think it's time bomb became slightly
older a little bit gray a little bit
wiser and there's no one less emotional
than me so I think job done come this
way Barbara um stay with me panel Neil
Ferguson thank you very much brilliant
to have you on the program really
enjoyed your name thank you very much
indeed
well coming up my interview with
psychologist Dr Jordan Peterson as next
week and his riveting one person who met
him before I did uh in Britain was the
strictest head teacher in the country
the tiger head mistress who is praised
and vilified in equal measure I'm just
not quite sure why she ever gets
vilified we're going to be talking to
Catherine bubble Singh after the break
it should be live and Unleashed
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
well welcome back to Peter's
organizations for those who think cancel
culture is real no further than Britain
strictures have mistress Catherine
bubble Singh she runs the Michaela the
community school at a private part of
North London the school focuses on
discipline and manners it's called boot
camp discipline detentions given for
lateness for eye rolling and hunting for
forgetting to bring in a pen quite right
too you might think not everyone shares
that you've said to me you really want
to be at this school you've said to me
that you understand why the rules are
here and why you need to behave yourself
I can't fix this
Mr Bullock can't fix it
who's gonna fix it
you're the only one who can fix it
your mom and dad be so disappointed
well Catherine bubble saying I'm done
thank you for coming in it's great to to
have you on the show
um you've been at the center of news
again because you invited Jordan
Peterson you know I interviewed
yesterday and we're running it in full
next week we're going to run in a moment
on a few minutes a little bit more of
that interview about you and the visit
attitude of the school which led to you
having people report you to the police
for hate crimes simply for allowing
Jordan Peterson to come to your school
which says everything you need to know
about the absurdity of modern society
and Council culture we'll come for that
part of this in a moment first of all
you're the tiger head mistress what does
that mean what is your teaching style if
you were to Define it simply well we
believe that the adults should be the
authority in the room the parents and
teachers should be in charge
um and that means leading the learning
it means desks being in rows and the
children looking to the teacher who who
leads the way
um it means high standards of discipline
so people think oh you know I must hate
children because
um I and then I must walk down the
corridors with whips and chains when
when actually you know I'm in school
every morning at 6 45 and I don't do
that because I hate them it's because I
love them and I know what they need to
be able to succeed they don't need
phones no well and that's another thing
so we wouldn't allow them phones but in
fact we go more than just we don't just
ban them in school we strongly encourage
parents not to give their children
Smartphones at all you can give your
child a brick phone uh you can still
ring them you can still text them but
they're not getting unsupervised access
to the internet uh do you practice you
practice tough love teaching for one of
a better phrase yeah why has it
attracted any controversy I mean your
results are outstanding yes you take a
lot of very deprived kids yes who don't
have any privilege in their lives yeah
you just had 98 pass rate in your gcses
I think yeah many a star level so you're
doing an amazing job yes helping these
kids achieve their potential and yet
there are people out there who'll be
listening to this now and going this
sounds horrible terrible This Woman's
evil yeah have we got to this place well
I I think people think it's mean to give
children detentions and to discipline
them but the thing is is that if you
don't do that then the children will
just been out of control yes and I'll
tell you what's mean it's living your
life uh functionally enumerate and
functionally illiterate and there are
lots of people who end up doing that
because school didn't do the right job
by them and hold their standards high
for them
are too many schools just too soft and
is the softness coming from being
terrified of this new culture again
where people say if you do anything to
do with discipline then you're bullying
you're racist whatever the excuse they
can think of to play the victim they
play it hard and teachers just get
scared they don't want to have to
operate in that environment
I don't think that they're just scared I
think all of our society really uh
encourages us to think like this so in
order for a head teacher to to do things
properly in my view you've got to be
quite Brave to stand up to the Mob I
mean for instance I invited Jordan
Peterson to come and just walk around
the school and see the school just as we
have 600 other visitors who come and see
the schools of all different Persuasions
politically and socially and everything
else exactly because you believe
presumably that actually the best
education is to have a wide range of
different people with different views
yeah but you know this is completely
going out of fashion in our education
system yeah universities now if you
deviate either one iota to the right you
get low platform you get shamed there
are protests going on yeah this kind of
woke cancer culture is out of control
yeah and so that's why as a head teacher
you've got to be quite Brave and that's
I think it's a little unreasonable in a
way to ask that of of ordinary people
who are just trying to do a job teachers
my own teachers for instance I have to
really support them emotionally because
they come to work at our school and
their friends question their decision to
do that they wonder what they're doing
are they actually do they not know who
they really are
um and and I have to support my teachers
and I said well how can I convince my
friends that I'm not a bad person I mean
I think this is completely insane I know
you're having to to comfort your staff
who are working in a highly driven
motivated environment which is
successful with happy successful
children coming out better than they go
in and you're having to help your staff
because they're being treated so badly
by their own friendship groups because
they're working in this environment and
it's nuts I know and the thing is is
that those people say that they want to
help deprive children and here we are
transforming their lives and yet they're
highly critical and they're some of them
who would really like to see us shut
down we're going to take a short break
come back we're going to play the clip
from my interview with Jordan Peterson
where he talks about his visit to see
you at your school a visit that as I say
it led to people reporting Catherine to
the police for a hate crime just by
having Jordan Peterson attend the school
this is insane and we'll talk about it
after the break
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back I'm still here with my
expert panel and Catherine bubble Singh
Is Britain's strictest tiger mistress Ed
teacher's great title I love her
um I gave it to you um but let's let's
play a little clip from my interview
with Jordan Peterson which has a full
next Tuesday in which she talks about
his visit to Catherine's school and this
absurd development when it all got
reported to police
you went to a school really interesting
School the Michaela Community School in
North London run by this fascinating
head teacher Catherine berbil Singh who
runs a pretty tough school but has
amazing results at this school and as a
result of you going she got bombarded
without from people and she took it on
head on actually and went yeah I'm sorry
we're going to keep inviting people with
all different views all different types
of people and that's going to include
people like Jordan Peterson she owned it
and she was proud that you went to her
school tell me about that visit what do
you think of her as well well people
think of her school as tough and that
she's this Dragon Lady and that isn't
what I saw what I saw was that she was
playing a very sophisticated game with
her students and games have rules
and if you don't enforce the rules then
the game doesn't play properly and every
game has a referee because someone has
to enforce the rules and she's a very
very sophisticated referee and she's
playing an unbelievably sophisticated
game and the students are so alert and
on target
their attention is so well regulated by
themselves like for example when we
walked into her classrooms we walked
into about seven we were LED round by
three relatively small kids who were
very articulate and together and
attentive and polite and focused when we
walked into her classes the students
didn't
turn their eyes away from their teacher
to look at us there was no buzz of
conversation they were just focused on
their teacher and their teacher was
focused too it's like we could walk in
and the whole thing just continued
around us and that was really something
to see and fast-paced man the teachers
were spitting out information as fast as
I've ever heard anyone spit out
information and the students were
reacting like just like just like it was
choreographed and the truth is it works
I mean recently this school that's
annoying yeah right it's annoying for
those who immediately howl this is
disgusting these poor kids oh yeah 80 of
the students achieve four plus C or more
in their GCSE is a very good results
despite being non-selective right that's
a big deal a huge deal
and yet she gets castigated for it which
says to me that my sort of gut feeling
that we've just gone a bit soft enough
it's annoying when you help out the
victims because then there's no one to
be like narcissistically compassionate
about them so and that's certainly the
situation she's in yeah it's quite
amazing that she's managed this with
with kids who are a non-selected sample
and I asked her you know well how many
kids do you have to expel let's say for
serious misbehavior and she said it's
only been a tiny handful and I said well
how many kids can't adjust to the more
rigorous pace and she said well they
they can all adjust and that's what I
saw I mean I never saw I never saw a
bunch of children a group of children
that were more focused and alert than I
saw at that school and it was really
part rending in some sense Yeah by you
going there they people actually
reported her to the police for a hate
crime yeah just by your presence in that
school that's the problem with hate
crime legislations like who defines hate
and I know the answer to that who
defines hate the people you lease want
to
so you know you want hate crime
legislation you just better keep in mind
who's going to Define what constitutes
hate and then you think about the people
you're enabling these rat Finks these
people who didn't learn not to uh
tattletail on their peers when they were
children who run to totalitarian
authority to wield their resentful power
now that's all part of the legal code
it's like well we'll see where that goes
well we know where it goes It goes so
that you know
demented half-wit resentful narcissists
can rat out Kate herbal sing to the
police yes yeah well that's not good not
at all and who knows where it'll end up
well it's not good uh Paula
what's your view of this the the tiger
head mistress is here yes do you agree
with the tough love strategy of this
school I I don't see the word love in
that title I see tough
but I don't see the word love and what I
wonder is whether you have changed the
physical came into an emotional cane
because what I am seeing is children who
are being taught through fear
um there are children who are being
taught to fear uh the authority they're
not being told as a panda mum I think is
the the opposite would tell their child
about being creative about exploring
about understanding about investigating
about challenging authorities
respond to that specific charge
in order for children to be creative or
to think outside the box about something
they need to know about it first and
that means they need somebody taking
charge and teaching them and when you
teach them and when you show up every
day at 6 45 in the morning as many of my
teachers do you don't do it because you
dislike the children you do it because
you love them and if you came to our
school you say you're seeing this stuff
but you haven't been to our school if
you come to our school and go through
the corridors as Jordan Peterson did and
as 600 other visitors do every year come
to our school most of them teach us from
all around the world and certainly
across this country they come because
they cannot believe what they're seeing
not just how loved the children are how
resilient and how determined and how
ambitious they are that these are
ordinary children from the inner city
and yet they defy the odds and we talk
about wanting social Mobility this is
how you get it all right
you talk about fear but actually at the
heart of this is actually respect
respect for the fear of respect no
respecting the setting that you're in
respecting that your teachers are there
to give you uh the the tools that you
need to do well and you say that there's
no love there but what better love can
you give children than allowing them to
maximize their full purpose what is
wrong with discipline by the way
do you have children
not that that wouldn't make me an expert
to comment no I'm sorry I actually think
you do need to have children as a
comment on whether tough lovers well she
has children but sorry absolutely exists
tough love is where you love your kids
but you believe in discipline and you
believe in in making them respect things
like school things like teachers they
don't have woeful disrespect for any
plank of society suggest that a parent
doesn't believe in discipline but has to
be tough discipline is something very
different discipline can be effective
when you respect your child discipline
does not have respective enough to want
to make sure to make you want to make
them successful tough love is loving
them enough to hold the line it's much
easier to just try and be friends and
not loving them so much that actually
you forget about discipline you let them
walk all over you they get No Boundaries
no respect they get what they want and
become entitled little brat which is
what happens to a lot of kids days
because they get covered in in Cotton
wool at every stage of their education
that weak schools run by weak head
teachers and finally we get a head
teacher who understands this from
personal experience and believes that
actually tough love is the right way to
educate our kids and I say hallelujah
yeah and I'm sorry I wonder I just
wonder
um what these children will be like as
adults
buy various muscles if you go to various
Russell group universities you will see
them that's where our kids are who
started with us in 2014 they're
articulate they're kind they're grateful
they're decent people they're the kinds
of people the thing I'm most proud of is
not our results it's the kinds of people
our children end up being the adults and
you see Paula if you don't mind me
saying it seems to me you have reached
these conclusions without being there
without actually witnessing this result
from stuff you've read and on Twitter
you're to some people the devil the
reasons are completely baffle me right
so I would say you have to have a bit
more of an open mind about what they're
really doing are you going to get away
and I'll bring my I'll bring my three
children as well okay
when we we have to comment on what we we
see in here so I've never been to your
school of course I haven't and I can
only comment on what I understand the
definition of a tiger mum is and what we
know about speak now do I sound like I
hate children but I have said that you
hate children that's not my suggestions
there's no such thing as tough love yeah
and that just that saying alone it's an
oxymoron you can't have toughness of
course
is love and respect oh please now that
can flow with discipline absolutely but
you can't get all discipline is a form
of toughness
discipline is a form of protecting your
child but allowing them to learn
sometimes I have four kids and sometimes
they range from 29 to 10. and sometimes
you've got to show tough luck you've got
to be tough on yourself you don't give
them what they want no you punish
I'm friends with my children but I but
I'm their parent I'm not their buddy I
agree with you I'm their parent but I
believe absolutely in tough love I would
have loved them to go actually they went
to very good schools all of them so I
don't criticize where they've been but I
would have had no compulsion they sent
them to your school yeah if you're not
tough with them then you just let them
do whatever they want and that's when
they're not safe that's when they're in
danger it's for us as adults when
children push we push back and if we
don't do that we let them down and what
you don't do it seems to me if you don't
do this you don't prepare them for the
real world the real world is tough right
it's a hard place it's full of knocks
it's really tough out there particularly
now for young people coming out of
school and universities probably never
been tougher actually in my lifetime and
they've got to be properly prepared
mentally physically prepared how can
they challenge authority in your school
we have 40 seconds Catherine how can you
prepare kids for the Big Bang Adult
World
well you teach them lots you make sure
that they know how to read write and add
up and all that stuff that can only be
done in a classroom where there's some
quiet where you can hear the teacher
teaching and where you can be inspired
to want to learn and so that and as
Jordan Peterson said you know they were
regulating themselves you build those
habits into them bit by bit and at the
end we talk about being top of the
pyramid it's just who you are and if you
discipline kids for not having a pen
would you have disciplined King Charles
III for his health first about is pen
leaking definitely yeah
it shouldn't be he would agree with you
by the way uh great debate thank you to
my panel thank you very much for coming
in please come back again all of you
that was a really good debate that's all
but tonight uncensored Keep It
Uncensored good night
[Music]
what was my biggest career moment after
spending about 25 years of Fleet Street
there's loads of stories I could tell
you but actually I think I did an
overnight stroke at all radio in the
early days the night of the brexit
referendum and that was actually quite a
milestone because of course we started
off thinking
um the remain had won and at half past
two quarter three after Nigel farage had
already said he'd lost it turned out he
hadn't lost but it turned out we were
leaving the European Union so that was
quite a shocker
this is talk TV news
good evening I'm Emily Rose Adams
there's a warning that the UK may
already be in a recession as interest
rates rise to 2.25 the highest level in
14 years it means some mortgage payments
will go up meanwhile the 1.25 rise to
National Insurance which came in in
April is being reversed in November
according to the new Chancellor
quasiquartang says it'll save 28 million
people 330 pounds a year the Kremlin has
started drafting plans to call up
reservists to fight in Ukraine yesterday
Vladimir Putin announced he wants to
mobilize 300 000 more Russians which has
sparked protests across the country and
there's now going to be three days of
major disruption on the railways in the
first half of October fresh strike dates
been announced for the 8th so for now
we'll have more after the talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you